hey what's up guys my name is Jenna and
I am going to talk about love and air
today cuz I'm gonna do it yeah that's
right I'm gonna do it um and that makes
me pretty excited cuz it's been a while
since I did it I actually did it last
August and puffy broker don't even know
what love and areas but I'll get to that
in a minute um yeah but basically all
you guys need to know for those of you
can do know what it is is I'm gonna do
it and it's in like four days so yeah
anyway so let me get them to expanding
this video so what is loving that Laden
dare um is Latin to button for me then I
guess okay it's Latin for to give a game
and I guess it would be pronounced like
them direct but I'm anyway soul adam de
is a 48-hour game programming
competition in which you basically have
48 hours to make a game based on a
particular theme so again we have no
idea what the theme is that they
actually gets released when the
competition starts obviously and yeah I
mean yeah yeah 48 hours making gambus
the any of you guys can enter it's
completely free it's um yeah it's
actually a really good experience for
those of you is still learning and
aren't too confident about if you can
make a game at all this is actually
great learning experience like there's
no like you don't have do anything you
just said it sit in your house and
pretend during the competition and if
you actually do finish something you can
submit it and people will judge you but
seriously it's really good idea and I
encourage all of you guys to get into it
me specifically that I actually did it
last August ooh they mentioned but I've
got a lot I like doubled my subscribers
since then so the most of you probably
haven't actually seen you do it I did
live stream the entire thing on youtube
so you guys can actually go to my
channel and find those videos they're
like probably a total of about 20 hours
long all of them there's like three I
think were the first ones like 11 and a
half hours long um but yeah so what I
want to be doing is I am going to be
live-streaming at eight game
this time okay um I will live streaming
again but I'm going to sort of let you
guys decided where I'm one experiment I
could have the stream it on YouTube
again like I did last time or I could
stream it on Twitch now stream on twitch
is a bit more complex for me because I
actually have to you know contact
machinima and tell them to basically
changing a contract because in my
contract at the moment says that I'm all
I heard me about a stream on youtube
because that's sort of what I picked
back in the day because I'm back then I
was like oh sure mine usually that'll be
fun but you know it's obviously not it's
kind of the I guess I want to say that
the excitement of streaming on YouTube a
sort of died down it's been like a year
um so yeah so in other words if you guys
do want me to stream on Twitch just let
me know basically as soon as possible
and I'll sort out the contract stuff
because that could take a while but not
like I'm happy to stream on either
platform to be honest I guessed which
just means i can listen to copyrighted
music and don't worry about it and that
could be fun but anyway the point is i
will be live streaming it the entire
development of whatever game i choose to
make which i haven't decided Elvis say
that really depends on the theme but if
you guys want to play the game that I
actually made last time it's called
Genesis I made every asset for it
including the music and all the sprites
obviously and the code in 48 hours and I
actually probably spent a little over 20
hours on it because I had a few school
projects to do as well I had the whole
weekend but I thought it was pretty good
the link to that will be in the
description so you guys can play that
game and yeah I mean Vladimir 26 is in
four days in 13 hours 56 minutes and 56
seconds with me actually recording the
song got the web page up and so if you
guys don't know when my stream will
basically start it will start as soon as
a competition stars and if you guys want
to know when the competition starts I
will link you guys as well Adam datacom
for such compr and you guys there's like
a little time on I like not only a timer
but it's counting down towards when the
actual competition starts that is when I
will go live so you guys can see like to
the second but all probably to the
minute that arm go live but yeah I'll
stream the entire thing it should be a
lot of fun it'll be on Saturday in
Australia Saturday 1pm I think it starts
but yeah if you guys want to know
exactly when it starts you can go to
love and debt or combo such compelling
cos in the description and you guys can
check out exactly when it starts but
yeah it should be a lot of fun it was
a lot of fun last time and hopefully
I'll make an awesome game and hopefully
you guys will learn a lot from either
doing the competition yourselves or
watching me make a game from scratch in
48 hours the footage on the screen right
now by the way is from the game that i
made last lat him de which was in august
and that was actually last Laden that
last blood him there that I did so that
footage is on the screen if you guys
want to play that game it is in the
description below one more thing about
that game though genesis there is there
are a few bugs obviously I matted in
like 20 hours the only map that actually
works properly because there's three
maps is this one and you can't actually
choose a map you get it just randomly
chooses one for you so make sure you you
get the one that you see on screen right
now is like a little island that's the
only one that works properly other ones
a glitch because the spawn area for for
the npc mobs is too much it's too high
um because i accidentally multiplied it
anyway point is it's just it's too large
so only the island mount work work work
care so only the island map works
properly um and the other thing is I'm
actually legitimately gonna just step up
the music for this one as well I may all
the music for last um lot of that but
what I want to do this time is and I'm
legit and saying this I'm what a freakin
like write a song like I'm only kidding
i like seeing something and we're going
to have a lot of fun as well with that
so like it's going to be legit to me
freakin legit so make sure you guys are
tuned into that because it's gonna be
legen dary anyway i will see you guys
then goodbye